well that's a good question i I've known
these people for a long time I started
Rosie in 1980 so oh that's 30 years ago
I felt like 15 years ago now 30 years is
that 30 years ago 1980 oh my god and I
can honestly say in this case that this
little girl with black curls and
enormous Siamese blue eyes came up to me
tugged on the sleeve of my shirt and I
saw her and I knew her name and it turns
out my father had a character named
Casey Ferguson 30 years before that in
one of his novels and I don't even
remember reading it but I love the name
I thought this was great and then I
wanted to write about alcoholism because
I'm in a sober alcoholic but I wasn't at
the time I got sober in 1986 but I was
so fascinated by what was happening in
my interior landscape that this
wonderful adorable religious
high-achieving person simply could not
stop drinking if I had one I wanted to
write about that partly for my own
salvation and then all of a sudden one
day there was a knock at the door of the
Ferguson house and they were lonely
family the father has died and Elizabeth
that the mother is shy and depressed and
there's this big zaftig woman with a
kind of Gibson Girl haircut and she's
new in the neighborhood and she has
decided that she and Elizabeth our new
best friends and so then one day she
tricks Elizabeth into going to a
backpacking trip but she really
minimizes what it will involve and
elizabeth is just enraged not a backpack
sort of girl but they meet these two
guys and get drunk with them up at the
campfire and chance at marrying one so
little by little they reveal themselves
to you if you're open and receptive to
to what would be the truth of their
lives and their arc and their thinking
and and their growth or their setbacks
my main problem is over and over again I
try to get all my characters to say
stuff that I just think it's so witty or
area diet you know so that everybody
will go whoa that inland what it's like
so brilliant and then I have to go
through and take it all out I do a final
draft
where I go through and take out all the
lies but I you get to know them little
by little and you you don't always know
it's like like real life you don't know
the answer you know God or life or your
own psyche doesn't have a magic wand and
you ask something and all of a sudden
receive the answer it's a process and
little by little I can answer the
questions of my characters predicaments
and what they might reasonably come up
with as a response to crises
everybody assumes that almost everything
I write about it has a teenager and it
is a direct telling of something that
Sam went through which is not the case I
mean I'm the teenage girl drug addict I
love drugs I smoke the non-habit-forming
marijuana every day for about 20 years
and so people can I I'm powerless over
what people assume to be either fact or
or not and so people assume that stuff I
write about in novels happened and
mostly the emotional truth of the
characters is autobiographical because
I'm really the only person I know all
that well and mostly what happens and
then all those never happened in real
life then with imperfect birds I had
five girl five young women who have all
been very druggie and/or have mostly
grown out of it with one exception and I
did very long and extensive interviews
with them and I would ask him why would
you do this with the guys what do you
get in return why would you do that drug
if it keeps leaving you so crazy and in
so much trouble I know the answer to
that because it's mood altering and
anything better is anything is better
than feeling small and kind of afraid
all the time so but I had these five
sources that really helped me understand
the psyche of the American druggie girl
in the high achieving druggie girl and
then I have been a parent of a teenager
and I talked to a lot of the other
parents and I said why did we not how
did we not notice this or that or the
other why were we so afraid and so Sam
has certainly given me bad bad nights
and and what left me wanting to just
clawed my own throat with exasperation
you know the feeling that no worse
parent had ever existed except for maybe
Jeffrey Dahmer's mother but I think
that's what all novelists do you draw on
your own material and you talk to as
many people as you can
you